[Music]
the fda says abbott's michigan facility
is expected to be up and running again
soon we are on track to get open within
the next week to two weeks so what
happened was
simelac
who owns the plant that got shut down by
the fda
is the single biggest producer of baby
formula in the country
the federal federal government shut it
down
using
the fda you know what i mean like using
a government agency
[ __ ]
i wanted to see
i just distracted him i knew it was
going to work too holy
what's the rule about hot reporters
hot friends she is
[ __ ]
hot honest question if you ended up with
any of those would you have any problem
no be like this is wonderful no but i
mean if you you feel like say you
imagine walk up for the three of us
right so we were frozen and we go to
frozen hey frozen you get the ugly one
ever be like which one's the ugly one i
will say this the one on the left
is the one that i think
or maybe the one on the right if you're
one of those two you'd still think yeah
you'd be happy but if you're back your
mind you'd be going
in the middle all right
can i help you out can i change can i
change it a little bit
what are we thinking here wow
what are we thinking here
dude all of her friends and but i'll
tell you what right now
here
right here which one do i pick redhead
every single time every time in this
situation the redhead the redhead the
redhead for sure because hot redheads
are that they're like yeah they're nasty
very hard to find oh yeah oh yeah
disgusting um but the hot redheads are
you know like the redheads are usually
like the hot ones are like one and five
one in four it's kind of too so when you
land a hot red head you take the hot
redhead
um
[Music]
anyway so we got distracted sorry milk
so the government shut down simelac
using the fda right that's the
no
you keep doing it enforcement arms can't
you're not allowed to be distracted go
ahead
and enforcement arm you were an
enforcement officer and then the
president
um
stop doing this okay i'm sorry
um go ahead what happened with the
formula what happened with the formula
the president uh
he uh
invoked the
national defense production act
and gave all the money oh boy
i warned you there was a lot oh boy man
she is outrageous
she's over doing it with the lip liner
but
yeah you're right [ __ ] her
protection act do you breastfeeding
i'm not doing it yeah you're gonna put
another one up
here
again my hands are up so you shut down
similac who didn't donate to the biden
campaign
oh my god
wow
there isn't a bad photograph of this
woman it really isn't holy [ __ ]
all right all right go ahead sorry no i
don't forget it
she's hot though
all right jesus how many are there
frozen
i told you there's a lot look i'm just
gonna close my eyes and plow through
this so
uh simelac all right
uh didn't donate to the biden campaign
the fda shuts down similac over safety
concerns on the plant i'm not looking
and then
he does the national [ __ ] god damn it
man
wow
come on man
although we haven't reached the end
nestle is a huge contributor to the
buying campaign and he gave all the new
contracts to nestle to produce this
emergency formula so nestle's going to
make a whole bunch of money and
similac's getting [ __ ] and it's all
because they donated to biden's campaign
i got it out i'm done though wow
by the way you know she's hot because
those jeans are absolutely [ __ ]
[ __ ] but on her
and if if you put those jeans on even
another attractive woman they wouldn't
work you'd be like you know she's hot
but those jeans are just [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay
sorry by the way jim and i have been
playing tennis with these yeah they've
been going they have been going back and
forth
ah come on i know i know jarring i know
okay how about this one you want this
one what is this what's this chunk no i
don't want this one